non-minimalists
i have a five-month-old son and so it's
been five months since myself
and my wife have had a good night's
sleep
oh man it's been about about 10 years
for me but anyway
um do you have a 10 year old son no i
just
sleep like garbage yeah we'll talk about
that in a second i think i think that's
actually this would be a good time to
talk about it uh josh how has
having a child change your idea or
practices
as a minimalist so um let me just say
this uh
ella is not a special needs child she is
a special once
child she has very special ones
and uh um she
she when she was really young
special once i'm sorry that's good
uh i was going to say something earlier
when you talk about sitting cross-legged
on the couch
yeah are you no cross like it on the
floor oh you oh
are you afraid that that's cultural
appropriation
and if so what does your sister think
about i'm gonna be honest i don't
believe in cultural appropriation
your sister doesn't get mad about it no
no no she does does it correct you or
anything
okay that's good um so anyway
thankfully so during ella's waking hour
so not thankfully for this
when ella was really young especially
before she turned three
um man she was
trying out for al qaeda
[Laughter]
they're hurting for members man well i
mean she
clearly was top of the class
and but but thankfully she
sleeps like a rock man she sleeps 11 or
12 hours a night oh my god i'm so
jealous
yeah and me too and like i get tired
just thinking about
her sleeping for 12 hours a night it's
unbelievable but the rest of the day she
wakes up and she's an instant tornado
and
like what says tasmanian devil yeah
that's pretty much ella throughout the
entire day
and then all of a sudden she just
crashes at night um
so it works out well for her but um
that's not answering silvio's question
how has ch having a child change your
idea or practices
as a minimalist well i mean i realized
that minimalism
i knew this before but it became more of
a practice
now minimalism is not about deprivation
you and i say that all the time but
i remember at first like i kind of
wanted um well you know kids don't
really need
any toys they're happy with whatever
they have and i was really just
projecting my own childhood onto her
like because i didn't have many toys
or the ones i did were crappy although
in my neighborhood i had more toys than
anyone else that's how i made all the
friends
dude you had a sega genesis man i know
that's how i made
literally all the friends in there
because they would come over and play
sega genesis i thought you were rich
because you're going to sing a jedi we
were on food stamps and i had and i was
rich
hilarious yeah anyway you're jamming
around yeah yes
oh man we were good at tow jamming all
right we're patched back in after that
commercial break
yes i mean how has minimalism changed
or how's having a child change my idea
of simplicity or minimalism i've
realized that minimalism is not about
deprivation i knew that in theory but
now i know it in practice because
i don't want to deprive ella of having
the things that she wants now
the average child has 300 toys but plays
with only 12
daily wow that tells me something here
that is a metaphor
for our own lives because the average
adult has
300 000 items and plays with you know 12
000 daily i don't know what the number
is but like
it's not even that right of course and
and and so
we just tend to accumulate more once we
get older and we're allowed to
accumulate more
and so ella has toys i take ella to the
toy store
but i also instill the practice of
contributing
to her as well so we go to the goodwill
once a month and we
let go of some stuff that she's no
longer playing with and she doesn't
realize like i'm just getting rid of
this stuff
so it's not the me explaining the theory
of of
contribution to her because she's not
gonna understand that she's five
but what she does understand is hey i'm
not playing with this anymore
i can see another kid playing with it
and i understand that i don't need this
anymore and if i get rid of this
i can bring new toys into my life that i
will like that i will enjoy
isn't it crazy like how kids love to
help man
like whether it's like you know with
with anything they just love to help but
especially with contribution i could see
where that would
be exciting for ella or at least being
able to understand like oh like i'm
going to give this to another kid
they really love to help me they want to
hit the garage door button they want to
like
everything yeah the key like they want
to help with everything and the same is
true with contribution and so
the thing that i've learned is yes ella
does great with a box of toys but if she
had 10 boxes of toys or 100 boxes of
toys
she's not going to be 10 times or 100
times happier in fact
uh especially with someone like ella who
has uh
well it's called spd sensory processing
disorder
and uh she just gets over stimulated by
sensory items especially physical items
and
loudspeakers loud sounds and bright
lights her first words
were mine eyes mine
yeah because the sun was bright she goes
mine eyes
[Laughter]
those are her first words what is he
like reading shakespeare or something
yes
yeah so um uh the the so she
the clutter with her is actually it it
like with me it stresses her out
and so we make sure that you know she
has just the appropriate amount of toys
and if she stops
playing with something then not i don't
donate it she donates it so there's
someone who's going to ask what what is
the appropriate amount
what's 12 daily that's 12. 12 new toys
daily
no i and i'm not actually asking for a
number well no the reason why i bring
that up is because
the number is the appropriate amount
there isn't a number
that you can spread across the board
with every child and say this is the
appropriate amount yeah i did a whole
video on this
with ella actually on our youtube
channel it's uh we did one of the living
room conversations sean if you can put a
link to that in the show notes
um we talked about how many toys kids
should have and i had ella talk about it
she was playing her trumpet on the video
as well and so uh we just we were
playing like fire truck and hospital
um on the the the she likes really gory
things which is disturbing like
she's like we went to go like buy some
like what was called playmate
the the sort of playsets that you put
together is that playmate i think
something like that anyway we went and
bought it and she was like going i want
the
the surgery room and i'm like okay she
wants to be a doctor
she's like i want a serial killer one of
the other i want the morgue
how do you know that word
you